last night after a gruelling two weeks
alok sharma president of cop 26 appeared
close to tears as he apologized to
delegates that the final text of the
agreement was
imperfect his word but he later insisted
that there was consensus and support for
the glasgow deal
for his overall take on this historic
summit i'm now joined live from glasgow
by mr sharma
good morning
can we just first start with that
breaking news from uh whitehall that the
queen
will not be joining the ceremonies this
morning
i imagine that that will be
a matter of some disappointment to you
and other members of the government
well look uh obviously i'm very sorry to
hear that but uh i'm just got the news
the same time as you as i understand
this is precautionary and of course we
wish her majesty all the very best
we um
of course uh witnessed uh the emotional
ending of uh cop 26 uh yesterday evening
and um much of that was focused on
you was the
uh your reaction exhaustion
uh after two weeks or just or
disappointment at the last minute change
from
phasing out coal to phasing down coal
well trevor you know when we started
this whole process two years ago we said
that what we wanted to achieve at
glasgow was to keep within reach
the temperature goal of limiting
temperature rises to 1.5 degrees we
delivered on that
there were very many people who doubted
it we delivered on it and actually that
was acknowledged by some of the most
climate vulnerable countries by some of
the climate ngos as well and i'm very
pleased about that not only that but we
also closed off all the outstanding
elements of the paris rulebook the paris
agreement after six years it had not
been completed we did that here that is
historic and we also ensured that there
was more money coming to support
developing nations
and therefore i think what we've
achieved here is something really quite
remarkable now on the issue of of coal i
should point out trevor that for the
very first time in any of these
conferences the word cole is actually
reflected in the text that again is a
first yes of course i would have liked
to ensure that we maintained the phase
out and rather than changing the wording
to phase down but you know on the way to
phasing out you've got to phase down but
ultimately of course what we need to
ensure is that
we continue to work on this on this deal
on the commitments and on the on the
issue of coal china and india of course
are going to have to justify to some of
the most climate vulnerable countries
what happened you heard that
disappointment on the floor so what i
would say to you that you know overall
this is a historic agreement we can be
really really proud of it but of course
this is just a start we now need to
deliver on the commitments
i i fully understand uh your feelings
about the achievements but um
let me just ask you
personally what are your feelings this
morning towards the countries who
insisted
on that last minute change from phasing
out to phasing down we're talking india
china i imagine australia was somewhere
in the mix
well look i mean i think on the floor
that you heard interventions from china
and india
at the end of the day my job was to
build consensus that's what i did i
ensured that
before we actually went back to the
podium i had checked with the
negotiating groups or some of the most
climate vulnerable countries that they
could accept the language and of course
they reluctantly did so because overall
this is really a very good and historic
deal but as i said at the end of the day
china and india are going to have to
justify themselves to these climate
vulnerable nations
but you know what some of those
developing countries are
feeling this morning
uh bitterness
and the sense that the big polluters the
usa china india australia
got what they wanted and that they are
going home empty-handed and some of them
to tell their people
that they better prepare themselves
to evacuate
or have their countries extinct
well trevor what you heard from the
floor yesterday was first appreciation
of what the uk has done but also
acknowledgement that this deal does
indeed keep 1.5 within reach and i can
tell you i've had lots of messages since
last night from ministers in many of
those countries
thanking us for what the uk has done
for the fact that we've managed to close
off the paris rule book for the fact
that there is more money on the table to
support them as i said this is a start
we've got one year of our presidency we
need to make it count and that means
that we need to hold countries to
account for the commitments that they've
made and those commitments have to be
translated into action and for the very
first time trevor in this deal what we
have got is an agreement that next year
countries are going to have to come back
and look at their 30 commitments
we've got for the very first time an
agreement that every year ministers at a
high level are going to meet to discuss
this issue and not only that but there
is going to be a report every year on
how we are doing the tracking of these
commitments on on reducing emissions
those are all historic firsts but as i
said we need to now ensure that those
commitments are delivered upon
you you know as well as i do though that
there is deep skepticism
the
big countries promised 100 billion for
adaptation
12
years ago
it still hasn't been delivered
how will those countries how those
countries expected to believe these
commitments if
that commitment from way back then
hasn't even been fulfilled now
well look trevor uh you know i've been
to many of the climate vulnerable
countries over the last year and i
completely understand uh their their
sense of frustration uh you know if
you're living on the front line of
climate change and literally on a
day-to-day basis you're being faced with
that of course you're frustrated but as
part of this process one of the things
that we did do i asked other ministerial
colleagues and other governments to pull
together a delivery plan we know with
confidence that that 100 billion will
come in 2023 it may come earlier and
that over that five-year period from
2021 to 2025 we will have a 500 billion
plus to support developing countries
that is appreciated you talked about
adaptation well i can tell you that in
this text it makes it very clear that
there's going to be a doubling of
adaptation finance to support countries
by 2025. so we have made progress and
countries do acknowledge that but of
course there is always more to do this
is a 26th cop there will be another cop
this is a process but in this case i
think we can say with some justification
what we've achieved here is absolutely
historic
you said that
the pulse a one 1.5 is alive but the
pulse is
pretty weak
what is going to convince you between
now and next year in egypt that those
who are responsible
for
most emissions and most pollution are
really taking this seriously and they
haven't just kicked the can down the
road
well i think we will have to track the
commitments that each of these countries
have made and we've had some historic
commitments you know we've got uh 130
countries coming together to ensure that
by 2030 we're reversing uh deforestation
i mean that's covering 90 of the forests
in the world we've got a historic
agreements on on coal as well
no more international co-financing from
any of the g20 nations there is a lot
that has been agreed but you're
absolutely right we need to make sure
those commitments are being delivered
upon as i said in this text we have also
agreed that next year countries will
come back and we will have a look at how
they're doing in their 2030 emission
reduction targets that's a historic
first
mr chairman i'd love to carry on talking
to you about this so much to discuss but
as you know there is breaking news which
we have to address so
for this morning thank you very much
indeed for your time